[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend nichts in dieser
welt ist schwarz oder weiß alles ist
voller zwischentöne voller nuancen die
oft unerwartet kommen staunen lassen
oder verwirren das gilt auch für die
nachrichtenwelt es gilt auch für den
krieg in der ukraine ein teil dieses
riesigen landes leidet unter
fürchterlichen attacken der russischen
armee und den anderen teilen versuchen
die menschen so etwas wie alltag die
ersten die geflohen waren kommen wieder
zurück weil sie gebraucht werden wir
beginnen heute abend mit christian
kirsch und der aktuellen lage im
geschundenen südosten des landes
bilder aus mario pohl die hafenstadt im
südosten der ukraine ein trümmerfeld und
noch immer im widerstand gegen die
russische armee mehr als 3000 tote
melden die ukrainischen behörden heute
hieß es im zerbombten theater während
womöglich bis zu 300 menschen ums leben
gekommen
65.000 sollen dem apokalyptischen ort zu
fuß entrollen sein kein wasser kein
strom nichts zu essen keine zukunft
mario pohl ein desaster für die
russische armee die zeichen mehren sich
dass russland strategie in der ukraine
scheitern könnte der russische
generalstab heute mit einer
überraschenden einer erstaunlichen
ankündigung
das militärische potenzial der
ukrainischen streitkräfte ist
signifikant reduziert worden das erlaubt
es unsere haupt anstrengungen auf das
wichtigste ziel auszurichten die
befreiung des donners
ein strategiewechsel offenbar ziehen
sich teile der russischen armee aus dem
raum kiew zurück aus dem dorf jk 50 km
westlich von kiew haben die ukraine die
russen vertrieben
ich glaube sehr bald werden alle truppen
die hierher kommen voller angst abziehen
sagte er denn gott ist auf unserer seite
das haus gottes im dorf schwer
gezeichnet von diesem krieg
mehr als 1300 tote russische soldaten
räumte heute sogar moskau ein dazu
tausende verletzte
russische truppen graben sich ein
es herrscht stillstand an vielen fronten
und der russische militär pfarrer erlebt
eine große nachfrage nach
geistigen beistand
ist für viele soldaten die zu mir kommen
ist es die erste kommunion viele von
ihnen spüren das innere bedürfnis die
segnung nicht auf morgen zu verschieben
sind machismo
gymnastik im westen der ukraine in
limberg begraben sie derweil mit
militärischen ehren einen ukrainischen
kämpfer igor für dort trug getötet bei
einem russischen angriff nahe rafah
blase ist für uns in lemberg im westen
der ukraine
jörg guten abend ein land mit vielen
gesichtern im moment wie ist denn die
situation bei dir wie ist zu erklären
dass manche auch bereits wieder
zurückkehren
ja also wir haben das auch gehört dass
vereinzelt ukrainische flüchtlinge zum
beispiel aus polen wieder zurückkommen
sie sagen dass sie sich um die
zurückgebliebenen um die familien
kümmern wollen und vor allem wollen sie
wohl ihre felder bestellen präsident
selensky hatte vor einiger zeit seine
landsleute aufgerufen genau das zu tun
zurückzukommen die aussaat auszubringen
um eine noch größere hungerkatastrophe
zu vermeiden und dieser aufforderung
kommen wohl viele nach oder einige nach
zumindest vor allem wenn sich ihre höfe
in relativ ruhigen gegenden befinden
denn man muss sich vorstellen das ja
eigentlich nur in weniger als der hälfte
des der des landes hier in der ukraine
tatsächlich kampftruppen
aufeinanderstoßen das konzentriert sich
auf den osten auf den südosten des
landes und die region um kiew aber in
anderen landesteilen wie auch hier in
lemberg ist es relativ ruhig ergibt es
vereinzelt militär luftschläge auf
militärische anlagen aber ansonsten
merkt man eigentlich gar nicht hier in
lemberg dass krieg ist hier kommen
natürlich flüchtlinge durch insofern
merkt man das dann schon hier wird auch
nachschub organisiert und auch nachschub
truppen die dann von hier aus also vom
relativ ruhigen westen dann in richtung
der kampfgebiete verlegt werden und dann
jörg eine meldung die heute abend
aufhorchen lässt wir haben sie im film
schon kurz gesehen da geht es um eine
zwischenbilanz die der vize-chef des
russischen generalstabs heute gezogen
hat und der sagt man könnte jetzt die
haupt anstrengungen auf das erreichen
des haupt ziels richten die zitat
befreiung des donners da kommt natürlich
die frage auf ändert russland jetzt
seine taktik ist da vor ort irgendetwas
von auszumachen
also das ukrainische sicherheitskreisen
hiess es heute man habe durchaus
beobachtet dass die russischen truppen
sich umgruppieren aber der
stellvertreter der stellvertretende
leiter des generalstabs sagte man dürfe
die kampfkraft der russischen truppen
nicht unterschätzen der gegner sei nach
wie vor sehr schlagkräftig diese meldung
gehen ja zum teil zurück auf
informationen aus den usa wo man
beobachtet haben will dass die russen um
kiew um zb gar nicht weiter vorrücken
sondern die hauptstadt nur aus der luft
beschießen und mit artillerie
andererseits hat die russische seite vor
einiger zeit schon betont dass man
eigentlich gar nicht mehr vor habe einen
regierungswechsel herbeizuführen und die
hauptstadt einzunehmen sondern dass man
sich eben auf das hauptziel des krieges
die einnahme die befreiung des donners
konzentriert also im osten und südosten
der ukraine vorgehen will und wenn man
jetzt kräfte um kiew zusammen zieht dann
vielleicht auch um ukrainische kräfte zu
binden aber das eigentliche kriegsziel
das wird nicht aufgegeben ganz im
gegenteil und dass er kann man hier in
der ukraine eigentlich einen
taktikwechsel nicht erkennen es wird
gespannt sein zu sehen wie sich die lage
in den nächsten tagen entwickelt jörg
brase in der ukraine herzlichen dank in
polen das eine 500 kilometer lange
grenze zur ukraine hat und eine grenze
zur russischen exklave kaliningrad in
polen sagen sie wir können den krieg bei
uns
das land setzt auf unterstützung durch
die usa parteiübergreifend heißt es nur
auf den verbündeten in washington könne
man sich wirklich verlassen und deshalb
ist der besucher der heute mit airforce
one in polen an kam ein hoch
willkommener gast der viele hoffnungen
erfüllen soll natalie steger mit seiner
ersten station beim polen besuch will er
ein zeichen setzen bei us-truppen in
rzeszów keine 80 km luftlinie von der
grenze zur ukraine entfernt und beiden
damit nah am krieg wie bisher noch nicht
auf 9.000 us soldaten hat washington
sein kontingent erhöht zur abschrecken
ihre generation steht an einem
wendepunkt die frage ist wer wird
herrschen demokratien und die werte die
wir teilen oder autokratien
beiden will unterstützung zeigen für
sicherheit an der nato ostflanke und für
die flüchtlingssituation in polen kein
land hat so viele ukraine aufgenommen
mehr als zwei millionen menschen bislang
ein großer teil bleibt im land der
amerikanische präsident mit polens
präsident beim briefing mit
hilfsorganisationen
morgen soll beiden ein auffangzentrum in
warschau besuch
ich bin hier um aus erster hand die
humanitäre krise zu sehen
wir sagen nicht flüchtlinge sondern
gäste das sind unsere brüder aus der
ukraine die sich in einer enorm
schwierigen situation befinden duda
bedankt sich bei beiden aber polen will
mehr mehr us soldaten mehr sanktionen
das dürfte man morgen bei bilateralen
gesprächen fordern heute der tag der
solidaritätsbekundungen es ist ein
signal an moskau der westen ist geeint
der präsident direkt hier bei der grenze
um zu zeigen das ist auch nato
territorium dass wir verteidigen
die polnische freiwilligenarmee hat
derweil enormen zulauf in polen ist die
angst vor einer russischen aggression
gestiegen im notfall wollen sie ihr land
verteidigen wir sind mitnichten nur
natürlich listen
it unternehmer viktor meldet sich bei
der freiwilligen armee an er hatte noch
nie eine waffe in der hand jetzt aber
umgedacht wegen des russischen einmarsch
ins nachbarland
besonders der tod von zivilisten ist
auffällig in diesem konflikt
das ist das was viele personen hier
motiviert
niemand weiß was kommen wird und deshalb
bereitet man sich vor auf einen krieg
mittlerweile ist beiden in warschau
polen drängt auf eine härtere gangart
gegen russland doch es ist kaum
vorstellbar dass die usa deutlich über
die gestrige nato gipfel entscheidungen
hinausgehen werden washington will auch
morgen vor allem die geschlossenheit des
festes demonstriert
die einzige antwort der nato gibt es
alle zwei jahre in norwegen der heimat
des nato-generalsekretärs üben sie im
manöver cold response die geeignete
reaktion des bündnisses auf einen
fiktiven angriff von außen meist nimmt
niemand davon groß notiz diesmal ist
alles anders cold response ist die
größte nato militärübung in diesem jahr
mit 30.000 soldaten aus 27 nationen und
einem zeichen richtung moskau bis
hierhin und nicht weiter florian liste
norwegen
es ist abend der letzte funkspruch des
tages an ihre kampagne armut gebert
gebirgsjägern aus würzburg muss die lage
im blick behalten und noch schnell für
vorrat sorgen irgendwo in nord norwegen
hat ein fiktiver angreifer das land
attackiert die nato soll zurückschlagen
wer das beobachtet muss sich immer
wieder zwicken es ist nur ein szenario
das ist kein spiel das ist den wir auch
wirklich dazu sich da auch wirklich mal
zu üben auch zu sehen vielleicht dann ja
wohl seine eigene grenzen auch einfach
das klima hier mitzunehmen die die
stresssituation wenig schlaf vielleicht
auch manchmal diese kälte wenn man
nachts aus dem saft raus muss und müssen
ja alles erfahrungen die braucht man und
daneben auch in einer echten situation
realen situationen auch bestehen zu
können wie mit ihr 30.000 soldaten aus
27 ländern das manöver lange geplant
eigentlich routine doch jetzt wo
norwegens nachbar russland an dem krieg
führt ist alles anders unabhängig davon
auch das wetter kein neuschnee wie für
gewöhnlich im märz es regnet und wie der
klimawandel macht vor keinem manöver
halt so wie jetzt ist es am härtesten du
wirst du hast am tag es friert in der
nacht wenn du keine heizung hast kannst
du deine kleider nicht trocknen das wird
sehr hart aber das macht das training
nur besser
das training das allein genügen soll
damit er zu trainieren de ernstfall
nicht eintritt und so hat die nato
bewusst tv-kameras eingeladen ein
manöver auch für die öffentlichkeit die
bilder sollen schließlich auch in
russland wahrgenommen werden das land
war übrigens auch eingeladen wie
international üblich als beobachter teil
zu nehmen der kreml aber verzichtete
heute besuch des nato-generalsekretärs
jens stoltenberg der nun ein jahr länger
im amt bleibt um die nato komplett neu
aufzustellen auch mit deutlich mehr
manövern
access als die alliierten müssen mehr
trainieren wir leben in einer
gefährlicheren welt wir müssen
sicherstellen dass unsere truppen aus
den verschiedenen ländern
zusammenarbeiten und bedrohungen aus
allen richtungen bekämpfen können
helmut gebert hat derweil mit ihrem team
alles wieder aufgefüllt es geht zurück
in die stellung in den kampf mit einem
erdachten feind der hoffnung dass es ein
planspiel bleibt
und jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten
von heute und die hast du ja na ja und
da blicken wir zuallererst auf das neue
digital gesetz der eu dass die
marktmacht von internetriesen wie google
amazon oder facebook beschränken soll
große anbieter dürfen ihre eigenen
produkte künftig nicht mehr bevorzugen
so muss beispielsweise die installation
von alternativen app stores erlaubt
werden außerdem soll bei messenger
diensten die kommunikation über
verschiedene anbieter hinweg ermöglicht
werden bei verstößen drohen strafen in
milliardenhöhe
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
appelliert an die bundesländer die
korona hotspot regelung jetzt unbedingt
zu nutzen
er geht davon aus dass es wegen einer
hohen dunkelziffer mehr als doppelt so
viele corona neuinfektionen gibt wie
offiziell erfasst das robert koch
institut meldet heute
296 1498 neuinfektionen das sind
1347 weniger als vor einer woche
288 todesfälle kam hinzu die sieben tage
incidents steigt weiter auf 1.700
56,4 der
ehemalige fdp bundestagsabgeordneter
jens maier darf sein amt als richter
vorerst nicht mehr ausüben das hat ein
dienst gericht in leipzig entschieden
der 66 jährige mayer wird vom
sächsischen verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem eingestuft nachdem er im
herbst den wiedereinzug in den bundestag
verpasst hatte war er mitte märz in den
justizdienst zurückgekehrt das urteil
geht bis zur entscheidung im
hauptverfahren
darin geht es um die versetzung meyers
in den ruhestand
weltweit hat bei der sv future heute zum
klima streik aufgerufen und auch in
deutschland gingen zehntausende auf die
straße wie zum beispiel hier in berlin
insgesamt gab es aktionen und
kundgebungen an etwa 300 orten in
deutschland eine zentrale forderung der
bewegung ist der ausstieg aus fossilen
energieträgern und ganz aktuell der
importstopp von kohle öl und gas aus
russland
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber
das grundvertrauen dass deutschland auch
auf außergewöhnliche herausforderung
optimal vorbereitet ist hat ja einige
kratzer bekommen um es vorsichtig zu
sagen in der pandemie nach dem
hochwasser jedes mal wenn man wieder an
einer abgesackten autobahnbrücke
vorbeikommt so gesehen wäre es ja fast
ein wunder wenn wir ausgerechnet die
vorsorge für den militärischen
krisenfall perfekt organisiert hätten
jahrzehnte lang war krieg eine sache für
historiker und kein grund voraus zu
planen und nur um das an der stelle auch
mal zu sagen so sollte eine ideale welt
ja auch sein wer es sich leisten kann
bunker zu galerien und bars umzubauen
ist in einer beneidenswerten situation
das problem entsteht wenn keiner merkt
oder merken will dass sich die lage
ändert petra otto mit einer
bestandsaufnahme
öffentliche intakte schutzbunker gibt es
nicht mehr 0 so wie es bei corona
anfangs keine schutzkleidung gab und bei
der flutkatastrophe im alter keine
sirenen katastrophen sind nicht mehr
vorgesehen krieg und bedrohung durch
atomwaffen schon gar nicht für mich
schon ein bisschen erschrecken muss ich
sagen also weil man ja nicht absehen
kann derzeit wie die lage sich
entwickelt per se besteht die gefahr mit
sicherheit ja das ist hierher kommt auch
falls etwas passieren sollte ist es
natürlich schwierig da sich irgendwo
schutz zu suchen
bunker sind heute kult mit ausstellungen
und musik sie werden wie pflanzt und
bemalt weil 2007 bund und länder
beschlossen dass sie unnötig seien ihre
ursprüngliche funktion wieder
herzustellen das dauert und das kostet
und ob und wie welcher bunker gegen
chemie oder atomangriffe schützt hier
der ehemalige regierungsbunker das wird
gerade erst wissenschaftlich untersucht
wer kennt denn noch die
unterschiedlichen alarme und warnung
dauerton fünf töne vier töne der
bundesweite wahltag 2020 zeigte auf wie
schlecht das system funktioniert
vielerorts blieb es ganz still
zukünftig soll es besser klappen durch
sirenen plus lautsprecherdurchsagen plus
radio und fernsehen plus waren app viel
hilft viel hoffentlich
im zuständigen bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
nehmen sie die derzeitige lage ernst
trinkwasser würde aufbereitet heißt es
man halte treibstoff für
notstromaggregate und nahrungsmittel und
jeder könne auch selbst vorsorgen aber
eben richtig
die profis sorgen in aller ruhe vor nur
der amateur hamstert in der krise
deswegen biete in aller ruhe sich damit
beschäftigen was sollte ich im haus
haben um 10 bis 14 tage autark zu sein
habe ich noch ein radio dass ich ohne
strom betreiben kann wir halten auch
nichts davon jetzt jodtabletten zu
kaufen denn no tabletten sind kranken
vorbehalten bergen für gesunde er
risiken dass der ernstfall eintreten
könnte er hat ein politiker nicht auf
dem radar und die bevölkerung auch nicht
doch die momentane situation sie zwingt
zum umdenken
amigos da ist präsident des bundesamts
für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe und jetzt bei uns
guten namen nach freiburg im breisgau
als schuster
guten abend herr sievers wir können uns
noch an den letzten bundesweiten wahl
tag erinnern beziehungsweise doch nicht
so richtig der war nämlich vielerorts
nicht zu hören viele sie reden gingen
nicht haben sie das jetzt im griff
ja wir investieren seit anfang letzten
jahres schon intensiv in die
verbesserung unseres warnsystem das geht
um redundante systeme das heißt wir
verbessern den mix auch mehr analoge
mittel wieder das war eine erfahrung aus
dem landtag also das heißt sirenen
ausbau und da hat mein abend sehr viel
geld schon investiert wir brauchen mehr
ich würde gerne im nächsten fünf jahren
flächendeckend die sie reden wieder
ausbauen moderne sie reden das kostet
aber eine milliarde vorbereitet sind wir
umgesetzt wird auch schon wenn ich mehr
mittel kriege würde ich gern mehr
investieren das geld reden wir gleich
noch wendet dann alarm gibt herr
schuster oder alarm gäbe was soll denn
die bevölkerung dann konkret tun wo
sollen sie hin denn schutzräume wurden
2007 bei uns offiziell abgeschafft
ja ich bin auch vorsichtig bei dem thema
schutzräume die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
dieses land selbst wenn man so
entscheiden würde für 80 millionen
menschen schutzräume vorhalten könnte
das ist glaube ich theoretisch wir
hatten in den besten zeiten
vielleicht für drei bis vier prozent der
bevölkerung ich würde lieber ich würde
der bevölkerung raten in einem solchen
fall sofort nach hause das ist das
wichtigste fenster türen zu
lüftungsanlagen ausschalten vielleicht
vorbereiten wer was in meinem haus ist
so die so geeignet wie sich der keller
aus der heizungskeller ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir vielleicht solche
dinge fördern in privathäusern ich würde
mir wünschen dass wir das machen wir
auch jetzt eine bestandsaufnahme machen
der gebäude die wir haben ob das u bahn
schächte sind ob das tunnel sind ob das
tiefgaragen sind die könnte man
ertüchtigen der schlussphase klingen
auch selbst jetzt in dieser lage immer
noch so ein bisschen so wie einer der
für sich selbst raum und für seinen für
seine behörde raum finden muss gehör
finden muss bei den politikern in der
vergangenheit war es ja so dass wenn
ihre behörde gewandt hat dann wurde sie
häufig auch belächelt haben sie den
eindruck dass hat sich jetzt wirklich
grundlegend geändert
das ändert sich jetzt im zweiten jahr
also das muss man klipp und klar sagen
die korona zeit dass der hochwasser die
hochwasserkatastrophe in nordrhein
westfalen und dem aartal und jetzt die
jetzige lage wir haben eine ganz andere
stimmung auch eine ganz andere stimmung
in der bevölkerung
es geht jetzt nicht mehr darum dass wir
zustimmung brauchen die kriegen wir was
wir jetzt brauchen ist dass wir unsere
konzepte umsetzen dürfen es geht jetzt
hart darum ist mehr investition möglich
für den zivilschutz die
zivilverteidigung machen wir mal ein
paar konkrete zahlen da dran die
bundeswehr hat erreicht sagen sie 100
milliarden mehr soll die bundeswehr
bekommen zehn millionen mehr wir sind
für den bevölkerungsschutz im haushalt
vorgesehen das sieht jetzt nicht aus
nach zeitenwende
nein aber man muss auch sagen dass die
gefährdungsbeurteilung sich erst in der
fünften woche geändert hat in
deutschland also wir hatten eine große
zustimmung schon für den ausbau unserer
katastrophenschutz fähigkeiten aber bei
der zivilverteidigung war das bis vor
fünf wochen noch nicht so jetzt ist die
gefährdungsbeurteilung neu ganz kurzer
zeitraum und jetzt hoffe ich dass in den
nächsten wochen der haushalt ist im
deutschen bundestag erst im mai wird er
erst verabschiedet ich hoffe dass diese
neue gefährdungsbeurteilung dazu führt
dass wir für die zivilverteidigung
ertüchtigt werden und muss man sagen
sagen sie uns doch einfach mal was
würden sie sagen eine zahl die sie jetzt
brauchen damit wie sie wirklich dieses
land auf vordermann bringen können beim
zivilschutz wir wissen was wir jetzt tun
müssen wenn sie uns fünf bis zehn
milliarden geben dann verbessern wir
unsere fähigkeiten unsere reserven die
versorgungsstrukturen
entscheidend und wir sind der partner
der bundeswehr wir müssen im innern die
bundeswehr sogar unterstützen ich denke
5 bis 10 milliarden in zehn jahren wäre
ein betrag mit dem wir gut arbeiten
könnten sagt armin schuster der
präsident des bundesamts für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
herzlichen dank für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet es ist in voller länge zu
sehen in der zdf mediathek
die amerikaner versuchen schon seit
jahren ihr flüssiggas auf dem
europäischen markt an zu bringen ohne
großen erfolg denn erstens war es viel
teurer als das gas aus der pipeline
und zweitens wird es meist gefördert
durch umweltschädliches fracking mit dem
heutigen tag ist washington jetzt aber
ein großer deal gelungen ein sehr
attraktiver für die usa denn europa ist
in keiner beneidenswerten
verhandlungsposition es versucht
verzweifelt wegzukommen aus der
abhängigkeit von russland und schlägt
jetzt bei den amerikanern zu anne
gellinek
bloß weg von russischer energie das ist
die überschrift für diesen tag in
brüssel am morgen macht us-präsident
beiden den anfang und verkündet dass die
usa ihre flüssig gaslieferungen nach
europa auf stoppen werden dieses jahr um
15 milliarden kubikmeter die in den
nächsten jahren auf 50 milliarden
anwachsen sollen aber auch das wäre nur
ein drittel von dem was russland bislang
in die eu liefert nämlich 150 milliarden
kubikmeter gas im jahr der deal ein
riesengeschäft für die amerikaner und
eins das sich dank vladimir putin jetzt
wie eine wohltat anfühlt
ich weiß dass der ausstieg aus
russischem gas kosten für europa
bedeutet aber der schritt ist nicht nur
moralisch richtig sondern auch
strategisch
[Musik]
fast zeitgleich trete in berlin
wirtschaftsminister habe vor die presse
mit der botschaft dass deutschland
erfolgreich daran arbeite unabhängiger
von russischen energielieferungen zu
werden bei der kohle gelinge das besser
als beim gas hier brauche man wohl noch
zeit wenn man das alles zusammennimmt
dann sieht man dass wir weitestgehend
die russischen gasimporte
ebenfalls anders ersetzen können jetzt
rechnen wir damit dass wir schon im
sommer 24 bis auf wenige anteile uns
unabhängig von russischem gas gemacht
haben und immer noch zur gleichen zeit
ärgert sich in moskau die russische
führung über die offenbar wirksamen
sanktionen des westens außenminister
lavrov spuckt gift und gast sie
verschleiern ihre ziele noch nicht mal
die da sind die russische wirtschaft und
russland selbst zu zerstören zu brechen
zu vernichten zu ersticken da wusste
lavrov noch nicht dass es mit der
einigkeit der europäischen union am
zweiten gipfeltag schon wieder vorbei
sein würde die 27 staats und
regierungschefs und chefinnen verhaken
sich bis zum abend in einen langwierigen
streit darüber wie man die
galoppierenden energiepreise einfangen
kann spanien und andere südeuropäer
verlangen eine europäische deckelung des
gaspreises deutschland und die
niederlande lehnen das ab wir haben
diskutiert was man tun kann um die
preise nicht durch die decke gehen zu
lassen deutschland und viele andere
länder sind sehr skeptisch wenn es um
markteingriffe geht weil die gefahr groß
ist dass man keine gute wirkung hat was
die marktversorgung betrifft und keinen
nachhaltigen effekt erwirkt was die
preise betrifft eine einigung gab es
nicht aber immerhin die idee gas auf den
weltmärkten künftig gemeinsam zu kaufen
vielleicht der krieg in der ukraine hat
viel verändert in der europäischen union
aber eben doch nicht alles
wir bleiben noch moment bei den
umwälzungen in der wirtschaft durch
diesen krieg an die sind mittlerweile
nämlich auch an der supermarktkasse zu
merken viele lebensmittel sind teurer
geworden
und wegen des kriegs dürften die preise
noch weiter steigen warnt heute der
deutsche bauernverband und hat einen
forderungskatalog an die bundesregierung
geschickt valerie haller was kommt da
auf uns zu und was wird genau gefordert
also sie fordern beispielsweise eine
aussetzung der energie steuer im
gespräch ist auch brachliegende
ökoflächen ausnahmsweise wir bauen zu
dürfen um die produktion kurzfristig zu
steigern denn der hintergrund ist rund
30 prozent der weltweiten weizenexporte
stammen bislang aus russland und der
ukraine doch nun fallen die lieferung
größtenteils aus ein problem vor allem
für staaten in nord afrika wo
hungersnöte befürchtet werden auch
deswegen wächst der druck auf reichere
länder mehr anzubauen in deutschland
gibt es genug weizen aber lebensmittel
werden teurer von preissprüngen in
bislang ungekanntem ausmaß spricht der
bauernverband da aber keine knappheit
herrscht seien hamsterkäufe unsinnig
sind in den supermärkten aber an der
tagesordnung inzwischen rationieren
geschäfte schon öl mehl nudeln um
weiteres horten zu verhindern grund für
die höheren preise sind massiv
gestiegene ausgaben für strom kraftstoff
und dünger kosten die landwirte auf ihre
kunden abwälzen und die müssen auch
weiter steigende mit die produktion
aufrecht erhalten bleiben kann viel ist
tatsächlich auf die höheren gaspreise
zurückzuführen beispiel dünger für
dessen fertigung eine menge gas nötig
ist molkereien ölmühlen und
zuckerfabriken haben von öl auf gas
umgestellt und ihre co2 bilanz zu
verbessern
das kommt sie nun teuer zu stehen der
hohe gaspreis zieht inzwischen sehr
weite kreise vielen dank valerie nach
frankfurt
die diesjährige fußballweltmeisterschaft
wird ohne italien stattfinden der
amtierende europameister verpasste im
gestrigen qualifikationsspiel gegen nord
mazedonien die letzte chance auf die wm
teilnahme mit einem null zu eins die
ehrwürdigen gemäuer auf roms piazza cup
annika haben schon deutlich schlimmeres
erlebt aber das sportliche italien wirkt
in den grundfesten erschüttert von einem
welt desaster ist die rede zur hölle das
peinliche aus nur acht monate nach dem
em titel emotionen enttäuschung
unfassbar italien verliert
die lage ist ernst das zweite mal
nacheinander keine wm für uns das ist
in der nachspielzeit nimmt italiens
unheil seinen lauf in gestalt von
alexander teig kosten der einstige
palermo profi trifft für nord mazedonien
mancinis 11 düpiert die außenseite ein
ungläubiger partylaune in palermo und in
der hauptstadt skopje nord mazedonien
fehlt nur noch ein volltreffer gegen
portugal zum wm-ticket dass italiens
europameister kläglich verpassen
und das war die welt an diesem freitag
danke dass sie dabei waren wir empfehlen
ihnen jetzt noch unser heute-journal
update gegen 0.25 mit nah sagt er mir
von uns allen hier im heute-journal team
an
[Musik]
guten abend es ändert sich was beim
wetter dann von norden kommen dichtere
wolken heran bei west nordwestwind sonst
wird's heute nacht klar sein und die
temperaturen sinken auf plus 6 bis minus
3 grad morgen steigen sie meist auf 16
bis 21 grad im norden bleibt es bei 11
bis 15 grad kälter das liegt an
dichteren wolken nordöstlich von weser
und elbe und es ist nicht völlig
ausgeschlossen dass es in niedersachsen
oder auch in brandenburg für ein
bisschen regen reicht sonst aber strahlt
die sonne und daran wird sich auch am
sonntag und am montag wenig ändern am
dienstag dann aber kommt tatsächlich mal
nass von oben binnenschifffahrt und
landwirtschaft wird das freuen jeder
tropfen ist willkommen
sonne wärme kaum regen trockenheit wird
wieder zum problem zumal in städten die
allzu oft immer noch betonwüsten
gleichen bäume grünanlagen begrünte
fassaden und dächer wirken der dürre
entgegen so speichern grüne dächer im
schnitt 60 prozent des regenwassers und
verdunsten es erst nach und nach kahle
wände erhitzen sich im sommer auf 60
grad schützen pflanzen die fassaden
bleiben diese deutlich kühler umgekehrt
im winter da dämmen pflanzen die
wärmeabgabe und sie bieten lebensraum
für tiere vögel kehren zurück weil sie
an den grünen fassaden nistplätze und
insekten finden auf wiedersehen